creation of educational psychologist and
dr. Stewart wayton whose University
criminologist and the author of scared
of the kids curfews crime and the
regulation of young people gentlemen a
very good afternoon to both of you
John Druitt if I can start with you I
was trying to tally earlier on how many
times we've had this debate I got to
about half a dozen so it's a pretty
perennial one why does it seem an urgent
one to you I don't think it's so much a
question of it being urgent but it does
seem that England in particular is kind
of being left behind within the UK we've
got Scotland which is already on the
road to in implementing legislation and
Wales are consulting on it it's been on
the agenda of legislation for and
government legislation for quite a
number of years now but it doesn't
appear to be making much progress so we
did feel that this was an opportunity to
raise the issue again and hopefully with
the support of the tea you see that we
can we can start the whole process
moving again okay so waiting Stuart
other countries are doing it so should
England it does worry me this is school
psychologists you must have a very
negative view of parents if they think
that see in Scotland the law if you can
see my hand that will now be a crime in
Scotland if this passes which hopefully
it warned because I think but like it's
the case that the vast majority of
people in Scotland don't agree with it
and we can't seem to be having a
situation where apparently liberal
professional people are increasingly
criminalizing aspects of everyday life
that's why I'm trying to write a book at
the minute called the criminalization of
everything and every day I have a new
example of this or basically loving
parents who care for their children who
lightly tap their hand will soon be seen
as criminal that the man who's
introducing this bill and Scott and John
Finney
except that he himself smacked his
children and yet he says it's the same
as domestic violence so I'm wondering
whether perhaps retrospectively we
should arrest John Finnie being a child
completely it's just so it's so divorced
from common sense and people's everyday
reality well let's try it let's try to
pick a little bit John Rich I'm looking
at this quote from Mary bastard who you
know we've interview many times here
from the National Education Union quote
we need to ensure that children are
legally safeguarded in their own homes
how do we set about doing that we need
to define what the crime is and then we
need to prosecute the crime how do we
prosecute a crime in the home a parent
smacks a child presumably the child
would be called upon to denounce their
own parents or it's while we're back to
cameras tell me how this would work
that's certainly not the intention that
we have in raising this issue I think
our main concern is that this is about
changing attitude
so it's tokenistic signal that's that
says not-not-not intention to be
criminalizing parents just be clear or
anything at least sending out a signal
it's not it's not a real change in the
law it's signaling an intention and good
behavior in your mind well it is a
change in the law because it's a change
that would remove a loophole in the law
that removes the excuse if you like of
reasonable punishment to justify violent
behavior against children but you about
a tap on the hand right so but help me
with that definition John if you could
help me with the definition where's the
line that just so parents know if they
weren't about going to prison or
receiving a hefty fine for smacking
their child something which generations
of parents have done where's the line
Stewart Abele demonstrated a gentle tap
on the back of his hand where is it
well I don't think that one can draw an
absolute line on these things and that a
lot depends on the individual
circumstances and we certainly wouldn't
anticipate that as a result of any
change in legislation that lots of
parents would be facing criminal charges
but what we're looking at is to send a
message to parents who feel that they
still need to rely on physical
punishment to manage their children's
behavior that there are other ways of
doing it and that it's not something
that society in general and the
government in particular approves of
okay all right so let me just personally
act association in a public forum yeah
okay Stewart wait what would you make of
that it's not it's a change in the law
but we're not planning on sending
anybody to prison unless they've been
really naughty I mean it's happening all
the time there are laws being introduced
where they say this is a law but it's
not really a law we're quick we're
making it a crime but it's not really a
crime I mean if people want to make it
have a message start a campaign like
make arguments mitt have articles in the
in the press you don't send the police
round you don't create laws it's like
constantly now we're creating law after
law after law making things that as part
of most people's everyday experience
criminal and I think we have to start
asking a few questions about these esque
experts if these ask experts really
believe that smacking a child on the
hand is a perform of violence that
emotionally damages them I think we
really have to start asking how credible
are these experts you know seriously how
credible are they we know right that I
just self-harmed am i abusing myself if
I did that to a child that happened to
me as a child and my scarf I think I
speak to John I suspect he might say
what hang on a minute that's not what we
talking about we're in danger of
trivializing serious domestic abuse any
use of physical chastisement will be
steamed a crime and any form of violence
is equated with domestic violence and
equated with violence against adults
that is it's what's happening and it's
what John
also just said they talked about this as
a form of violence against children
that's exactly the argument that's being
made and it's it confuses the
distinction between adults and children
it also undermines parents Authority and
it puts across this idea that we need
experts all the time to help us parent
which is simply not true what would you
say to that John parents can't be
trusted leave it to the state not at all
we don't say we don't advocate or or
support that attitude the the issue is
about finding ways to support parents
who perhaps feel that they have to rely
on some form of punishment of children
to look for other ways to do it and also
to encourage government to actually put
in place support services that will
provide that information and that advice
to parents from all these experts to
enable them to adopt different methods
of child management particularly for
children whose behavior is difficult to
manage and who may come in for an awful
lot of physical punishment because
parents find that they've got no other
means of dealing with it and believe
that okay that's the way they should do
it I've got to leave it there I'm afraid
John Druitt and Stuart Wade and thanks
both very much thanks a lot